>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> I'd like to introduce
Chris Germain,
director of the Oberlin
Violinmakers Workshop.
>> Thank you.
Good evening, everybody,
and welcome.
Really happy to be here.
And before we get into
the program tonight,
I'd like to just give a word
of thanks to everyone here
at the library of [tape
skips] absolutely wonderful
to work with, and so supportive.
And there is no way we could
have accomplished this --
our goal of the story that
we're going to tell you tonight
without their total help.
And that's what we're
going to do tonight.
We want to tell you
what I think is going
to be a really interesting story
that's going to span 300 years
about violins, starting
with Antonio Stradivari,
and leading up the modern day.
But before we begin
to tell you the story,
I would like to have the musical
performance of the two violins,
the original Betts Stradivari,
which is in the collection here
at the Library of Congress, and a
copy that we made at our workshop
at the BSA Overland Workshop.
And to do that, I would like to
introduce two very fine violinists,
some friends, Claudia Chudacoff
and Christopher Franke,
please, both members --
[ Applause ]
Both members of the President's
own the Marine Corp, Orchestra,
who perform at the White House.
And I'll let you introduce
your selections.
[ Silence ]
>> First we'll play
the second movement
of a Leclair sonata for two violins.
It's a gavotte movement,
Dante Egratsia [phonetic], so.
[ Silence ]
[ Violins Play ]
[ Applause ]
>> Oops, sorry, one second.
I've got to take that
one [inaudible].
Next we'll play a duet for two
flutes by Telemann in G major.
It's sort of a fugue.
It's the second moment
of the first sonata.
[ Silence ]
[ Violins Play ]
[ Applause ]
>> So this was a chance to hear the
two instruments in a performance.
We thought you'd like to hear just
the clear sounds of a simple scale
on each of the instruments.
So Chris has agreed just
to play a simple scale.
[ Silence ]
[ Violin Plays ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Violin Plays ]
[ Silence ]
>> Well, Chris, thank you very much.
We are purposely not revealing which
instrument is which at this moment.
We thought we'd let
you keep these sounds
in your heads while
we reveal the story
of how these instruments came about.
Chris.
>> Okay. So we were kind
of sneaky with you tonight.
Usually, you start a
story out at the beginning
and work your way all
the to the end.
What we decided to do was end the
story with the most important part,
the music that's played
on the violin.
Now, I want you to keep all
of what you just heard
stored in your memory.
Think about what you just heard
because we want to get back to you
at the end, and would like to get
your feedback about what you heard,
what you think you heard,
and we want your story
about the music tonight.
But we have to start back at the
beginning and this is a project
which has taken years
to get through.
It's been a labor of
love and hard work.
It began some years ago
when John Montgomery,
curator here of musical
instruments at the Smithsonian,
had suggested for our workshop at
Oberlin College during the summer
to study a great instrument.
And we thought about
what might be available.
Back up a little bit and tell
you, sometimes I'll meet people
on the street, you'll
start a conversation up,
and the conversation
will lead to, you know,
"What do you do for a living?"
And then I'll say, "Well,
you know, I'm a violinmaker."
And it's always interesting to see
the response that you get back.
And usually, people
do one of two things.
Usually, they'll first
start to say, "You know,
I didn't know did that anymore."
[Laughs] and I assure them
it's still a viable profession,
even though we do things
pretty much the way
that things were done
300 years ago back
when Stradivari was
living and working.
But then the next thing that
usually bring up is Stradivari.
It seems like anybody anywhere
knows the name Stradivari.
And they always ask,
"What's the secret?
Tell me the secret.
It's got to be, like, you know,
one sentence that you can tell me
so I -- then I can make a
violin like Stradivari."
And this is something we makers have
dealt with for a very long time.
You know, it's my opinion, and
I think also the opinion of many
of my colleagues that there
is no secret to Stradivari,
that the secret was
his genius alone.
Here's a man with an incredible
80-year working period,
who was totally dedicated
to his craft in a time
that fostered the arts
like no other.
And through his devotion and hard
work, he became the greatest.
So if that's the truth, then how do
we discover what his secrets are?
Well his secrets, I believe,
lie right in front of us
within the instruments themselves.
And only through a
systematic study of them,
can we really understand Stradivari
and how we worked and hoped
to conceive an instrument in the
same sentences as good as he did.
So what we decided to do is like
a "Mission Impossible" theme,
put together the great dream team
here that you see in front of you,
many experts, mostly violinmakers.
But we have a radiologist here.
We have people with
great tactical skill.
And this was the theme
of our Oberlin Workshop,
to get the Betts Stradivari,
to systematically analyze it,
to gather information using
the highest technology,
and then also to incorporate
the technology
of today during the construction
of an instrument through --
well, they'll tell
you how they did it.
But let's go ahead and begin.
And I would like to introduce our
technical experts, Dr. Steve Sirr,
radiologist from Indianapolis,
Minnesota; and he'll be joined
with by Steve Rossow and
John Waddle to his left.
[ Silence ]
>> Thanks, Chris.
Thank you very much.
I'm a diagnostic radiologist.
I went to college for 14 years, and
I taught medical residents radiology
at the University of the
Minnesota for seven years.
And back in 1989 at Hennepin
County Medical Center
when I was responsible for
teaching residents radiology,
I had three really high-quality
residents that could take care
of the entire hospital for me.
And I became very bored on weekends,
and so I brought my violin in.
And I'm not a very good player,
but I brought it in to practice.
And one on Saturday afternoon,
there was a gunshot victim
who needed some rapid attention.
And so he came into the CT scanner,
and we knew that he was going
to surgery after the CT scanner.
And one of the young residents
was banging on my door
as I was practicing and said, "Dr.
Sirr, please come and help us look
at this scan so this guy can
go right away to surgery."
So I ran out of my office
carrying my violin down the hallway
and put the violin
next to the CT scanner.
And then we read the CT scan,
the patient went to surgery.
And then as I turned
around, I realized this --
my violin was next
to the CT scanner.
So I thought, "Well,
why not just scan this?"
And that was in [laughter] 1989.
And then I realized that there's
a lot of anatomy inside the violin
that I had no idea
what I was looking at.
And I had purchased my violin
from John Waddle, this
wonderful man here.
And so I took the CT scan
to John Waddle's shop,
and handed it to John
on one Saturday morning.
And John said, "What are these?"
And I said, "I'm not
going to tell you.
You have to tell me."
So I went back into his room
and started looking at some
of his old books that he had.
And all of the sudden John --
this is my version of the story.
All of the sudden,
John started yelling,
you know, "This is really great."
And, you know, I walked
out to where he was
and he said -- I said, "What is it?"
And he said, "This is
a CT scan of a violin."
And he said that there
were things in that scan
that he had never seen before,
which was just what I was
hoping that he would say.
So, since that time we've
scanned hundreds of instruments.
And we have scanned about 60
instruments that were made prior
to 1734, along with hundreds
of other instruments.
The study of the human
body is a lot --
is very similar to the study of
violins and stringed instruments.
The first thing I always
taught the residents was
that there's a very wide
range of normal anatomy.
And once you understand the normal
anatomy, then you can understand the
"diseases" in quotes, of the violin,
which are mostly due to trauma
or infestation by worms, or
a combination of the two.
And then just like the surgeons go
out and take the patients to surgery
to try to fix them, the restorers,
violin restorers go do the
same thing with the violin.
So in these old instruments, there's
always very interesting features
of the violin that we always see.
So what I thought I would do is show
today what a CT scan looks like.
And this is -- these
are two CT scans.
And I've them going
in synchrony here.
So you can see right here is
the lower block of the CT scan.
And this is this --
the bass bar just came
into view there in
both of these scans.
This is the widest part of
the lower bout right there.
And there's the F-hole, beginning
of the lower portion of the F-hole.
And you can see how they match up
perfectly as they go back and forth.
Also notice how the shapes of
the violins are exactly the same
and the thicknesses are the same.
This is the sound post area.
And you can see that right
here is a little black line,
and that's the sound post patch,
which we always see
on older instruments.
So this instrument is the
instrument that Strad made.
And this is the one that
was made with the CT
and the CNC process that we have.
And we scanned it -- after we made
it, we scanned instrument just
to show how good quality it is,
and how accurately it reproduces.
So then I'll continue up here.
And these are the upper corners.
I'll kind of go back and forth,
and you can see the upper corners.
This is the widest part of
the upper bout right here.
And then the sound post disappear
-- or the bass part disappears,
and both instruments are at
exactly at the same spot.
And then this is the upper
bout -- upper block here.
And this is the neck.
The neck has been refitted
here in the original.
And there's our neck.
And then going through the
ebony, of course, is darker.
It has higher density.
And then we'll come into the box.
Here's the box in both instruments.
And then, this is something that
I found very interesting, too.
[ Silence ]
This image right here,
this is the Betts scroll,
a cross-section of the scroll.
And this is the cross-section
of the scroll for the instrument
that was made with the CT
scan from this instrument,
the Betts instrument, and carved
with the CNC scanner
from the CT data.
And you can see that this
looks like it's crossed.
So I always thought that being
extremely devout Roman Catholics
that lived at the time in
Italy, they always tended to --
well they always thought about Jesus
and how important it
was to be a good person.
And so the violinmakers hid
the cross in the scroll here.
It seems to me to be pretty obvious.
And then I'll go back again.
[ Silence ]
So this violin, the new violin, was
made with wood that is very similar
in quality to the original Betts.
With CT scanners, we can
measure densities of woods
without taking the
violin apart, of course.
So we try to find wood
that is the same density,
has the same grain pattern,
the same qualities of wood.
And then use that to carve
with a CNC scanner directed
by the CT scan an instrument
like this, or that.
So that's my part.
[ Silence ]
And this is Steve Rossow,
a good friend of mine.
[ Silence ]
And Steve was an apprentice
for John Waddle.
And we meet at John's shop every
Friday after work for a session
that kind of turns
into a men's group.
[ Laughter ]
And one day --
>> But we still tell our wives
that it's strictly
professional and there's no --
[ Silence ]
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> Okay. So before I get
to that night where we kind
of figured something
out this was from --
by the way, yes, Steve Rossow,
violinmaker, St. Paul, Minnesota.
[ Silence ]
I had just -- actually, it was
about six years ago, maybe six going
on almost seven years ago, I --
a friend of mine, and I had taken
on a project to build a CNC machine.
And a CNC machine -- "CNC" is
"computer numerical control".
And it's basically a machine that's
a three-axis carving machine that's
driven by a computer.
That's a real basic
way of putting it.
If you have a three-dimensional
image, or a two-dimensional image
of an object, you can
plug it into the machine;
it'll carve out that part.
And you can get -- you know,
you can create drawings
in a CAD computerized design program
or other ways, like CT scans.
And so I had come into John's
shop on a Friday night about --
might have been about five, six
years ago, and had told these guys,
"Hey, I've got the --
the machine's done.
I don't really know
what to do with it yet."
But I had brought in
some parts that I made,
I think some inlays or
something like that.
And John and Steve, you know,
they had been CT scanning violins
for years, were already dabbling
in a little bit of this --
using these files to
create these plastic models
of the Betts Stradivarius.
And I think there was an example
floating around here of a scroll.
But that night, Steve had asked me
what file format my machine takes
to carve out a part.
And I told him, I go, "Well, if
it's a three-dimensional part,
an STL file, it's what I need."
And he said, "Well, I
think I can save this image
of the Betts Stradivarius
as an STL file.
Let's see what happens here."
And so he goes through that process.
He gives me this disk.
And I'm like, "Yes, well okay.
Whatever."
You know. [Laughter] And
I go back to my shop.
I think it sat on my bench for, you
know, a couple of weeks or something
like that before I even
thought about picking it --
you know, I thought, "Oh
that's, you know, a cute idea."
[Laughs] And so I finally
open it up.
It was this enormous file.
And what I -- what you see on the
screen right there is actually --
it's a program called "Rhinoceros",
which is a 3D drafting
program which I use.
And what you see is
a real fine mesh,
little triangles called "polygons".
And that's the file format that
the machine at the time it can --
you can take -- use
other file formats.
But that's, at the time, what we
were -- we figured out we could use,
and enormously dense,
about a million
of these little polygons
making up this --
the image of the whole violin.
And so the computer I had
at the time was old and slow
and it was just hard to
even manipulate this thing.
I got to the point where I was
able to trim the top off the sides
of the violin and trim the back
off of the sides of the violin.
And I just, for the heck of it,
took the file of I think the back.
It was the back, put a
piece of scrap wood, poplar,
something like that, fixed
it down to my machine,
set the parameters I needed to.
I hit "Go".
And it started carving out
the shape of a violin back.
I'm like, "Oh that's kind of neat."
And I got done with it and like,
"Wow, this is kind of neat.
I've got to show the
guys on Friday."
[Laughter] And pretty unrefined,
yet there still had a lot
of work to do with these files.
Brought it in, and they
were like, "Well, wow,
I think we might have
something here."
And, you know, "Go
work on it some more."
[Laughter] So I got
back, and I further --
you know, I had to rescale
things a little bit,
because of the translating
from Steve's computer
to mine was a little
different, and, you know,
the axes that they were placed on
was different than what I needed.
Refined it a little more, brought
in another one, looked pretty good.
Then I started adding
the purfling channel,
which is that decorative
strip that's in --
from the outline of the violin.
Working on the outline, eventually
got to the point of, you know,
cutting the F-holes, creating
the scrolls from these files,
which I have -- you know, I
have this huge cabinet full
of scrap things that
didn't work out.
So it was a lot of test
wood going into this.
And it got to the point
where finally, "Alright;
let's put some good wood in
here and see what we can do."
And finally carved out some
parts that were successful
and that were going to work.
And I have some pictures here.
[Laughter] There's the
machine, and there we are.
Here's a blank piece of wood,
really nice piece of maple
for a back being ready to carve.
And it's sitting on a cradle
that's vex, so it vacuums down,
holds it in place and locates it.
Here it is getting close to carving
out the outside of the plate.
And now the carving is done,
and now the outline is going
to get cut to clean up the outline.
And from there -- I don't
think we have pictures
of the purfling channel
and all that.
But so --
>> Are you using [inaudible]?
>> Yes; they're end mills; usually,
use our round nose, half inch
and mill for the carving.
And this is a quarter inch
end mill to cut the outline.
And then, I'll use a little,
you know, one point --
whatever the purfling channel width
is one point two, one point five,
to carve the purfling in this net.
So finally, we got to the point
where we had this really --
these neat parts that were cut out.
And then as far as the
connection to Oberlin,
I guess if somebody else
wants to talk about that,
we were invited to be part of that.
The mold is a whole different
thing, and I won't really --
we don't have time to get into that.
But here are some other pictures.
John.
>> This is John Waddle, the
third of the three of us here.
[ Silence ]
>> So I don't want to spend
too much time because I want
to give Jeff and Antoine
enough time.
But I first became aware of
the Betts Stradivarius in 1989
when the Strad Magazine published
a really nice article about it
by Roger Hargreaves [assumed
spelling], with a nice poster.
And I thought at the time, "Wow,
what an amazingly beautiful violin."
And so I kind of had it
in the back of my mind.
And years went by, and Steve Sirr
and I started CT scanning
instruments together.
And around the same time, Gary
Stern, who's sitting right here
in the front row, and his
cohort, Bruno Frohlich,
over at the Smithsonian, were
also CT scanning instruments.
And Steve Sirr and I were trying
to get scans of better instruments.
And so I started bugging
Gary Stern because I knew
that they had CT scanned the Betts.
And after a while,
he very generously sent
me the scans of the Betts.
And that allowed Steve Sirr and I
to study the Betts very closely.
And I ended up writing an article
for the Strad Magazine myself
on the Betts, which was
published in May of 2010.
And as a result of that
article, and as a result of Chris
and Raymond Schrier [assumed
spelling], and John Montgomery,
and other people deciding
to make the Betts the focus
of the Oberlin Project, I
was invited to go to Oberlin,
along with Steve Sirr
and Steve Rossow to talk
about what we had been doing.
And so that was a great honor for
me to be included in that group,
and to be able to study
these instruments is amazing.
I remember when I was in the
violinmaking school, if a Strad came
to visit the school, it was
always a really big deal,
and everybody would
just drop everything.
And just to be in a room with a
Strad was a tremendously big deal.
But to have the detail and
the ability to study something
so closely is way better
and more interesting.
So it's been a long project
and it's been really fun.
And like I said, I'm going
to be short and give it
over to these two amazing guys
over here, who did the varnish work
on one of those instruments there.
[ Laughter ]
[ Silence ]
>> While they're getting
-- can you hear me?
I can just shout.
While they're getting set up,
this is Jeff Phillips,
this is Antoine Nedelec.
They are not always
joined at the hip.
They work independently in Salt
Lake City and in Dallas, Texas.
They're old buddies and they're
great friends of ours at Oberlin.
And their role was to come on out
and do their genius with varnishing.
And the work that they do
is absolutely fantastic.
When you're a violinmaker,
the thing that brings --
draws fear into your heart
the most is when you have
to start painting it;
putting on the varnish.
And then to do that in front of
50 other colleagues breathing
down their neck was
an incredible feat.
So in advance, I'd like to thank
you guys for what you've done.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Hello. Jeff Phillips
out of Salt Lake City.
>> And I'm Antoine
Nedelec from Dallas.
So we have a few pictures but
fortunately, we do have a video
of the CNC machine,
if you don't mind.
[ Silence ]
I believe it went something
like that.
[ Laughter ]
Highly high-tech.
[Laughter] And you went 14
years to school for this.
[ Laughter ]
>> On a more serious note --
>> That looks very serious.
[Laughter]
>> After the instrument
had been put together
in the 2011 Oberlin
Workshop, it's then --
takes a year to get ready
for the following year.
In 2012, we came into the workshop
and varnished the instruments.
So one of the first things we have
to do is get the actually wood
part ready for the varnish.
And so one of the first
things we do is put it
in a light box to get a suntan.
>> Lots of the really nice dark
colors you see on Stradivarius
and older violins come from
oxidation from simple exposure
to UV lights and things like that.
So there's the light box.
Oops.
[ Laughter ]
So you see those are just UV lights.
[ Silence ]
>> Follow-up with that, we put a --
>> Here it's -- yes.
>> Yes, yes; we put just
a mild solution of --
an oxidizing solution
on top of that.
That sort of helps with the color,
gives it that nice golden
brown oxidized look.
So you can see in the picture
there, so the white sort
of still unfinished instrument along
with the Oberlin Betts
before varnish is put on.
[ Silence ]
>> And varnish cooking.
It's actually -- everybody's
always looking for the secret
of Stradivarius with the varnish.
I believe that was very simple.
I -- and you can obtain a good color
just by cooking the resin longer.
The darker you want your
color, just cook it longer.
>> Yes; we use fairly simple,
sort of tree resins that come
from different places, just cooked
at different temperatures,
different rates.
And the process of
cooking, you just had to --
produces a lot of color that ends
up being in the varnish itself.
[ Silence ]
>> So Oberlin varnishing begins.
This is actually the
application of the ground.
And this one, we don't
apply it with a brush.
I'll let the video speak for itself.
>> And again, sort of
the purpose of this is
to also continue the
coloration of the wood.
So this is sort of put into
the wood, sort of rubbed in.
Just again, another cooked
resin applied with a rag
and then wiped off with spirits.
>> Yes.
>> If you wanted [inaudible]
to the acoustics of the box
as you were applying each layer?
>> Yes.
>> You know, as makers,
we tend to sort of prepare
for what the varnish is going
to do to the instrument.
It's not a huge change,
depending on what you use
and how much of it you use.
But it's something you definitely
have to take into consideration.
[ Silence ]
It can add weight, it
can stiffen the wood.
[ Silence ]
>> Going to --
>> So after the ground is
put on, if you take a look
at most Stradivari instruments
and a lot of Cremonese instruments
at the time, they put black
on a lot of the chamfers,
especially on the scroll.
A lot of it is worn off.
If you look on the Betts here,
you will still see
some ruminants left on.
So that's put on, just some black
ink painted onto the chamfers.
[ Silence ]
>> Next, we put a separator.
That step is to protect the ground
of the violin from being removed
when we start removing the varnish.
I'm not sure that that
[inaudible] varnish,
but it definitely works
for our purpose.
I -- sometimes I compare
[inaudible] a little bit
as sound editing in movie theaters.
You'll hear the noise of the horse,
and it's actually somebody
banging rocks.
So I'd say it's a little
bit like that,
meaning they did it 300 years ago,
and go and we just don't really
know exactly how it was done.
[ Silence ]
That's -- we apply the
superior with a brush.
[ Silence ]
>> And then we begin actual varnish.
So here's the Oberlin violin with
its first coat of oil varnish,
again, just resins cooked
in with linseed oils.
And in this case, we call this
the clear coat, the first coat put
on that does not have
any color pigment in it.
So all the color just comes
from the cooked varnish itself
and the wood underneath.
[ Silence ]
>> The color coat.
It's pretty self-explanatory really.
>> Variety of different things
you can use, earth pigments,
lake pigments, dyes, so forth.
In this case, we chose
an Elysian resonate.
It's sort of similar to a lake
pigment, but attached to rosin,
just something we were comfortable
with using, we knew its results
and something we were
used to working with.
[ Silence ]
>> So -- , yes.
>> Antoine putting a coat
on the Oberlin Betts.
>> You know, Sam, I don't know
if they applied the
varnish thin or thick.
It's very -- you've got some --
Filipe probably will know better
than me, but there's
couple of techs saying
that Strad applied really
thick varnish and he took force
to put it on the instrument.
And we just do it thin.
For me anyway, it works better.
I know plenty of people
would do it differently
and they get a very,
very good result.
And in violinmaker never say,
"My way is the only way."
There's plenty of ways of doing
good work; and bad work too.
[ Silence ]
>> And if you put it on thin,
you can put several coats on
and you can control sort of the
evenness of the coat as well,
color adjustments as well.
[ Silence ]
>> Time for lunch while the
coats are drying; very important.
[Laughter]
[ Background Sounds ]
Sorry, we don't have
a better picture.
That's actually the Oberlin
Betts before it was antiqued.
So it was actually varnished
to look like a new violin.
So some people sometimes will
start making the violin look old
right away.
Our process is to make
it look just like it did,
and then try to do 300 years' worth
of antiquing in about five days.
[Laughter] So antiquing begins.
[ Silence ]
>> So one of the first things we
do is crackling of the varnish.
And that's something that
I think most or a lot
of Cremonese instruments have
gone through over the times.
Although you tend not to see
it so much, because it's --
a lot of it's been worn away.
So what we see here is
a picture on the left
of a freshly-varnished instrument
that has had a crackling
process done to it,
just fine little fissures and
crackles into the varnish.
And if you take a look
at the picture
on the right is actually a
corner of the Stradivari Betts.
And if you look closely, you'll --
we'll just see some fine little
black lines, sort of through
in here is what -- where dirt and
patina [phonetic] would have gotten
down into the original
crackle before a lot
of it has been worn away.
>> So that's how the
crackle was done,
it's basically putting the
solution that's applied.
And what it does is it -- we hit up
the varnish with soft [inaudible]
and we apply that solution,
and it kind of shrinks
everything and creates a crackle.
So that's how it's done.
[ Silence ]
And yes, it can bubble.
[Laughter]
[ Silence ]
>> You can use a variety
of protein solutions.
In this case, we used
a gum arabic and water.
>> And the gum spreads
really nice to get a very,
very controlled thin layer.
And if you do it with a brush,
you could actually see the brush
marks on your crackle, so --
>> And then it's wiped
off afterwards.
>> Yes, yes.
Fascinating, huh?
[Laughter] No, no;
really, really fascinating.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, boy.
It cannot get any worse, can it?
[ Laughter ]
Chipping the varnish.
[ Silence ]
>> So the initial wearing of the
varnish here after the crackling;
so this was a lot of Cremonese
instruments you see that's sort
of fissuring and chipping of
varnish as things get scratched
and it gets released
off of the ground.
So one of the things we
have to do is make sure
that our varnish actually
works in this fashion.
So it does actually have
to be chippy varnish.
Using the right types of resins and
oil concentrations allow the varnish
to actually work in a
similar fashion to some
of the Cremonese varnish.
>> And you're very lucky to have
those violins at the Library
of Congress, because you don't see
that chipping on all
the old violins.
Sometimes they've been French
polished, and worn, and used.
That's -- those are really pristine
and you see that it's actually rare
to have it so good like that.
And here's a little video
of Jeff doing the chipping
on the Oberlin Betts.
The rocks he used actually
help in releasing the varnish,
creating little bumps and releasing.
[ Silence ]
We decided to turn the volume down
because I am not good at jokes
and I talk all the
time on those videos.
[Laughter]
[ Silence ]
And that's how it's done.
He makes it look easy.
>> And what is that [inaudible]?
>> It's tape.
So the rock kind of just initiates
the release of the varnish
and then the tape will
then pull it off.
[ Silence ]
It's a long process that goes over
pretty much the whole instrument.
[ Silence ]
>> Shading.
>> So then through the next
form of varnish wear is shading,
and it kind of refers to
the smoothing and braiding
of the whole varnish surface itself.
And we do this in a couple of ways.
One way is with alcohol; so alcohol
rags gently to remove the varnish,
hopefully in sort of
these thin layers.
It creates this nice
gradient of varnish.
>> Yes. If you look at
old instruments, you know,
they didn't have the
cases we had back then.
And, you know the chipping
maybe happened
where they were being banged during
travels or maybe, I don't know,
with the [inaudible] doing stuff on
the violin or as a kid, you know.
Or the shading may be more
of the actual player
rubbing against the violin.
[ Silence ]
So I'll call shedding.
And again, that's Jeff.
>> Yes. You can also do this sort
of abrasion, sort of sandpaper
and so forth, but find that it
tends to make just too smooth
of a glasslike finish, whereas
taking it off with alcohol
like this gives a much
more realistic look.
>> And again, he's
making it look very easy.
It's actually one of the
very difficult parts.
You could wipe off everything,
if you're not careful.
It's very good to have a varnish
that reacts well to alcohol.
I know I don't react
to with alcohol.
[Laughter]
[ Silence ]
>> And so once varnish has been
worn down, then we start putting
on patina, years and years of dirt.
[ Silence ]
>> Yes. You --
>> So yes, we start off
with basically pigments
in kind of an oil wash.
>> [Inaudible]?
Should I go back?
>> So that's a picture there
of the Stradivari Betts.
And this sort of gray hue that
you see in the wood and intermixed
in here in the chips and so forth
is patina that's been rubbed down.
[ Silence ]
And along with that patina, we
also do painting and touch-up.
So you can see on the left
Stradivari Betts F-hole,
and then sort of a work in progress
in the middle there painting
on some patina and sort of the
general effect there on the right.
[ Silence ]
>> Some French polish to
finish; Freedom polish.
>> Freedom; yes.
[Laughter]
>> Oh, you know, I'm in Texas.
I've heard that one a lot.
[ Laughter ]
[ Silence ]
French Polish is kind of
frowned upon now on old violins
because it's simply adding
something that wasn't there before.
It's there, and we're making a copy
and we're adding it to our violin.
So I think it's okay.
It's got a tendency to
blend things together.
And honestly, something is
needed to protect the bare wood.
So that's the Oberlin
group of 2012, right?
>> Yes.
>> The finished copy
and the real Betts.
[ Silence ]
Time to celebrate.
[Laughter] Ah, those burgers again.
And the end of our rollercoaster.
[Laughter] That's after the
alcohol and the burgers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Silence ]
The end.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you.
You'll never look at a
violin the same again.
[Laughter] So I know this is a
moment you've all been thinking
about, is what we started
the event with.
And let me first ask a question
-- and you can raise your hand,
how many people during the pieces
where both violins were played,
found that they -- both
instruments were equally enjoyable?
[ Background Comments ]
Okay. And then we'll
go to the scales.
How many people heard
differences in the scales?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
So that's a very interesting
thing to say there.
Together, they were extremely
enjoyable instruments.
The scales were different.
Of course, scales are harder things
to ask do we like or don't we like,
because it's just the sweat
that the musician puts
in to be able to create the music.
But I think the interesting thing
about this whole process is,
of course, it's so many
steps and so many years.
If we just talk about the scanning,
I think Gary started doing
it 12 or 13 years ago maybe?
And when he started doing it -- and
this is true of so many inventions
and progress, he actually didn't
know why he was really doing it.
And now you know why
he started doing it.
So all of these complicated
things come together
and create two incredibly
great-sounding instruments.
So we can cut to the quick.
In the first piece, Claudio
was playing the copy.
And this one is the copy.
And then they switched.
And in the scales, the
copy was played first
and then the Betts
was played second.
So, you know, this is all
information you can digest
and you can think about.
I think one of the
things I like to think
about is how the audience
has permission
to like everything
the way they want.
And I say that because
there's been a little bit
of a framework that we think about.
When I hand someone
or talk to someone
about a Stradivarius
before they even play it,
they already think it's amazing.
And so here was an opportunity
for you to truly hear them
without any preconceived notions.
The other person I wanted to thank
is a fellow named Bill Sloane
who was the donor to the Library
of Congress of this -- the Betts.
He's a member of the Oberlin
Workshop and when this was finished,
acquired the instrument
and then donated it here,
so we're very grateful to
Bill Sloane for having done
that because now we have the chance
to really compare the two
and see them together.
And the Library has
a great opportunity
to actually use both of them.
And the exciting thing coming
up Saturday night is the chance
to hear the debut of a new piece
of music here at the Library
on the new Betts Stradivari.
So we hope you'll all come for that.
So we have a few minutes to
open the floor for questions.
And I see one back there already.
And I'll bring you
the mic because --
>> Oh, we have one.
Okay; maybe you can wait
for the mic to come to you.
[ Silence ]
>> Hi. What wood was
used for the copy,
and how does it compare
with the original?
And secondly, is the heat and
humidity of the workshop important,
especially in the varnishing phase?
>> So the first question
maybe, Steve,
did you check the densities
of the different woods?
So maybe Steve Sirr can answer
the first question, and Antoine
and Jeff can answer the second.
>> With CT scanning,
we can determine densities
quite accurately.
So what we're doing now is
trying to find matching wood
that has the same type of
grain pattern and as close
to the original densities
as we could get as possible.
[ Silence ]
>> And as far as varnish
and humidity,
I think it has bigger
effect on wood than varnish.
I have no problem with it;
Salt Lake's so dry, you know.
[Laughs]
>> Plus it's pretty humid.
>> Yes.
>> So the varnish -- and oil
varnish doesn't dry with --
well, there is a little
bit of evaporation,
but basically you're going to help
me with a word that's complicated
for a French man, "polymerization"?
Am I saying it right?
>> Good enough.
>> Good enough?
So all you need really is UV lights,
and a UV box will do
even in humid climate.
[ Silence ]
>> Any other questions?
>> Yes; let me just stand
up real quick [inaudible].
One of the things that we found out,
which really ran counter to some
of the instincts we have as
violinmakers, generally, we --
in instruments we like
to see a top --
the wood on the top being
of relatively low density,
but high strength.
And the back can be
in higher density.
Also, we want it to be strong.
One thing that we could only find
through the scan of the Betts was
that the top was actually very,
very dense in the original
Betts Stradivari.
I think it was about point four --
four point four five, that region.
Most violinmakers today if we
had a piece of wood that was
of that density, we wouldn't use it.
And so just having the
technology at our disposal,
enabling us to know exactly what
the original materials were like,
helped us a lot in that.
>> And another interesting thing
about that is through the study
of dendrochronology, we've
actually found out that Stradivari,
and Guarneri, and many of other
great makers used wood that was
between four, five
and six years old.
So that kind of dispels
that thought that it has
to be some ancient timbers
from some Swiss chalet.
[Laughter] The wood
selection's important,
but it's still here today.
Erin.
>> Yes. Thanks.
What do the parts look like when
they come off the CNC machine?
And what I saw was like of
the arching and the outline,
but does it also do the
under -- the inside?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, okay.
>> We can also carve the
insides out, you know,
as well on the CNC machine.
But I think for the Oberlin Betts,
we had actually carved the outsides,
cut the purfling channel.
It looked pretty close; it
needed scraper work to be scraped
down to the final finish.
I believe the insides
we carved out --
>> By hand?
>> Yes; you know, each
piece of wood's going
to have a little different
stiffness to it.
So, you know, you can
kind of dial it in --
>> Right.
>> That way by hand, so.
>> Can I add a little
to some of that?
>> Yes.
>> I just want to add to that
that because we have the CT scans
of the original instrument,
we can measure the
thicknesses of the wood, too.
So when we're making the
copy, we know what those are.
And we can choose to copy
them if we wanted to or not.
[ Silence ]
>> And one thing I
would like to say, too,
is that even though my part of
the project is very high-tech,
there's quite a bit
of art in what I do.
And it takes probably five
to six years of just looking
at normal variations
and normal things
to realize what the art
of radiology really is.
So this is not just some
machine-made project.
There's a lot of art involved,
obviously, at every stage of this.
[ Silence ]
>> So I thought we'd take a second
and get another perspective.
We're so grateful that Claudia
was willing to play for us.
And, you know, when it all comes
down to it, it's the relationship
between the instrument
and the musician.
So Claudia, perhaps you
can give us a few thoughts
about what you thought
of when you played?
>> Okay. Well, we --
Chris and I arrived here
about a half an hour before you did
to play these instruments
for the first time ever.
And so that was interesting.
I think the thing I
was stuck by first
for sure was really more the
similarities between the instruments
than the differences
because, you know,
any two instruments can be
quite different in terms
of how you approach at
it, how you play it,
and what it sounds
like under your ear.
Now, I didn't know -- I
don't know as much as you do
about what it sounds like
at the back of the room,
but there is a real similarity
in character of the sound
that was very striking to me.
I would say there was
something about the Strad,
I have to just say it --
that is like it has sort of
an extra tubular bow kind
of gear or something like that.
[Laughs] But both instruments
are really beautiful
and very enjoyable to play.
[ Silence ]
>> I don't want to use that
word "turbo" with the Chrysler.
[ Laughter ]
Any other questions?
Yes.
[ Silence ]
>> One of the things that is
of interest to me is, you know,
in trying to recreate the sound
of a 300-year-old instrument
is this thought
of an instrument that's been played,
and the sound that has been
projected out of the instrument
for -- if it's been played
continuously for 300 years.
How do you try to recreate
that aspect?
And to me that's, you know,
the vibration from the
sound and the playing on it.
So has there been any
thought about that?
>> Well, let me also start
by saying that those of us
who build instruments find that
when the instruments are finished,
they actually sound quite
stunning, quite amazing.
So there is this thought that they
have to be played a lot and yes,
there is certain changes that happen
with instruments as they're played.
But we wouldn't be violinmakers
if they didn't sound really great
because nobody would want them.
So it isn't that we have to wait
until we're all dead before anyone
wants to have these violins;
[laughter] very important thing.
Also there was an interesting -- and
there's been many, many comparisons
over the years of new -- brand new
instruments and two, and three,
and four hundred years
old instruments.
And many, many times, and
most recently in New York City
at an event called "Mondomusica",
the new instruments
actually were preferred too.
So there is an interesting
thought about what happens to wood,
both as it's vibrated and maybe more
importantly as the wood changes,
because in a tree, it's
growing, it's alive,
the cell structure's full of
moisture and there's sugars
that later will crystallize
and the thing does dry.
So it's a very different piece
of material when it's old.
So we'll never argue with
that and maybe that's
that final subtle difference
that Claudia was referring to.
We'll see.
But I think to leave
you with the idea
that a great instrument sounds
great whether you vibrate it or not.
Well, you have to vibrate
it to hear it.
Isaac Stern used to always say when
they thought his violin sounded
so good, he would put it up to his
ear and go, "I don't hear anything."
[ Laughter ]
Any other questions?
Yes.
[ Silence ]
>> Have you, or do you have
plans to do any spectral analysis
of the sound from the instrument
or of the vibrational modes
of the instrument itself, you know,
not played with the strings but just
from an acoustic point of view?
[ Silence ]
>> Yes; that was one component
that we left out this evening is
that both instruments, the original
Betts as well as the copy went
through a series of
acoustical tests at Oberlin.
And we'll go ahead and continue.
The results have not been
let out to the public.
Yes; but we did analyze both
instruments and we found more things
in common than different
between the two instruments.
Yes, that's it.
>> John, did you [inaudible]?
>> No, I [inaudible].
>> Yes; it's being done.
[ Silence ]
Maybe one more question?
>> So I'm just curious, of
the various violins that are
in the Library of Congress or
other ones you have access to,
the comparison between these
two, and between this Strad
and other Strads, how -- I mean,
what's the magnitude of differences;
because you said that, you know,
there's obviously a range of normal.
Is there a range of,
you know, Strad?
Well, there's certainly
a range of Strad.
And are the differences here
within the range of the Strads
from the acoustical analysis and
any other analyses that you've done?
>> Well, the acoustical analysis
that are graphing the sounds are
certainly showing differences
on all the Strads and even on all
the other -- I mean, instrument --
sound is so complex
now that you can --
but I think you want to always
get back to that question
of what do we the listeners
like to hear?
And what do players like to play?
And if you do talk to many
players, they'll talk about Strads
that sound great and some that
they're not so happy with;
some that are easy to play and
some that are hard to play.
So that's going to be always there.
The question is you can analyze
it and you can look at it
and see differences, but then how
does that relate to what you like,
I think is a big question there.
>> But so are these two closer to
each other than this Strad is to --
>> To another Strad?
>> To another Strad; yes.
>> To be continued.
>> Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>> Okay; well thank you all very
much for coming this evening.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov